alcuni di voi già sanno che io sono un
grande appassionato di bear grylls o
anche tutti i suoi dvd in una puntata
ambientata in un isola deserta si
ritrova in mezzo al mare disidratato
come il deserto del gobi a ferragosto
durante il viaggio si imbatte in una
scogliera in cui trova dell'acqua stagna
è piena zeppa di escrementi di uccello
puzza ed è rancida ma per sopravvivere
la raccoglie comunque non potendola bere
come la ingerisce che domande si fa un
clistere soffrendo le pene dell'inferno
e tutto interessantissimo ma perché ci
racconti questo gli hot o b perché
questo è quello che ho provato io per
un'ora e mezza guardando prima vera di
granito film italiano del 2000 diretto
da ignazio frogheri c'è una cosuccia in
particolare da sapere su questa
pellicola ma ve la dirò poi alla fine il
film inizia con una citazione di anonimo
che dice per non imbattersi in un futuro
con delle comunità violente e quanto mai
opportuno correggere il presente che un
po come dire se non vuoi che il cane ti
cade in salotto non comprarlo ma il
pensiero positivo c'è andiamo avanti in
un'auto facciamo la conoscenza dei primi
due personaggi e qui mi fermo subito per
dire una cosa
il dialogo che sta per arrivare sono le
primissime due frasi del film queste vi
daranno la visione generale del livello
di qualità della sceneggiatura di questo
film
prego
ti sto aspettando papa andiamo quindi
biglietto che già tardi
ok andiamo che armi wow veramente
veramente non si sono accorti che questo
scambio di battute non ha un minimo di
continuità
amore puoi lavare i piatti certo caro ma
prima devono lavare i piatti
no quello farlo dopo prima pensa a
lavare i piatti e non ditemi è stato
fatto con pochi soldi perché non c'entra
nulla perché un foglio una matita e un
cervello per scrivere cose decenti non
costano niente arrivati dal padre
assistiamo a questo mi sono appena
passate un'agenzia ho preso io biglietto
per vedere la mia mente si fa piacere
sentiti ma non sarebbe il caso che mi
dicesti a parlare di vetrina in pensione
felice se al mio rientro
[Musica]
avete già acquistato la data di molti
casi non manca qualcosa in questa scena
tipo la recitazione o una qualsivoglia
tipo di emozione del dire una frase
ed ecco perché io mi sento così ogni
volta che sento un attore parlare evviva
accompagnano il padre all'aeroporto
mentre i due uomini
[Musica]
si dicono qualcosa ma il film ha un
mancamento e non ce lo fa capire mentre
tre brutti ceffi rubano in un negozio un
uomo vestito di bianco con una valigetta
sale una scala lo so sembra non avere
senso ma serve tutto per dopo arrivato
ad un ristorante con una roba che non so
cosa sia
lui le chiede di sposarlo ed ho parlato
stamattina amore bellissimo ma lele
deciso nello sposare non aspettavo altro
chissà come sarà felice troppa le varie
per renderli primo sapere della nostra
decisione
mio dio mio dio donna c'è un limite
massimo di schifo che uno può fare
recitando sono due le cose
oggi hanno pagato pochissimo e quindi te
ne freghi della prestazione oppure se un
cyborg venuto dal futuro per farmi
soffrire fa male ragazzi fa male
scopriamo che alberto è amico dei tre
sgherri di prima
scusami sono le modalità sono a parere
tratta da olbia ero convinto che abbiamo
ancora fatto una sera chiedo scusa a
tutti i sardi che stanno guardando
questo video ma ogni volta che li sento
recitare mi viene in mente nicolò il
tizio con il vestito bianco di prima
messi leblanc mamma il suo scagnozzo a
parlare con i ragazzi per fissare un
incontro vai infami sa bene dunque l'uso
john sinclair porta milionari di questa
città vuol saperne di più di queste
opposte sono ragazzi e tu sai tutto per
spesso quando salti mortali per momento
di forma anche se cioè cosa a volte
cercando air one cioè non avete nè vieni
qua così no no
la propone un buon affare interessa
farlo non riesco neanche a fare altre
battute sulla recitazione è veramente la
catastrofe della cinematografia italiana
per ogni frase recitata dal cast di
primavera di granito un uomo del mondo
viene ucciso tra l'altro complimentoni
per le musiche assolutamente non
fastidiose
all'incontro leblanc offre ai ragazzi
della droga in cambio di 300 milioni di
lire loro non li hanno quindi gli
suggerisce di rapinare un furgone
portavalori in questa piccola città
c'è solo un modo per averli a salire uno
dei furgoni portavalori reti rai soldi
dalle banche dalle poste e dai market
loro accettano e vanno via vado a
parlare con alberto per riferirgli tutto
ea voi quanto costa o alberto è davvero
un'occasione irripetibile cioè solo 300
milioni
lui rifiuta perché puro d'animo non fa
per me loro un po meno male blanc dice
loro di fare il colpo solo in tre e non
contento manda il pelatone ad incastrare
alberto per droga ok cosa leblanc e
quindi anche il suo scagnozzo non sanno
chi sia alberto perché non l'hanno mai
visto in vita loro
men che meno la sua automobile in cui
hanno messo la droga per incastrarlo e
ditemi che anche questi errori sono
colpa del poco budget
intanto oro dio stage e na i tre
dell'ave maria vogliono della droga ma
non hanno i soldi quindi scelgono la
loro amica nella rubinetti facciamo fare
in giro con la signorina
e lei accetta e questo splendido sipario
si chiude con la freddura meno freddura
più triste del globo terracqueo
beh almeno oggi non devo parlare
tromboni li avremmo già pronti
beh almeno oggi non devo rollare
tromboni li avremmo già pronti madonna
se brucia vittoria la ragazza di alberto
cerca di infiltrarsi dalle blanc per
ottenere informazioni ma viene catturata
questa scena è dedicata a tutti voi che
avete pensato wow
ma questa recitazione degna di un porno
ti faccio vedere io come si è tirata una
ragazzina e curioso
no è peggio
questi delle serve proprio perito a meno
tre canne questi hanno venduto l'amica
per tre canne ma questo è niente
l'altra volta mi sentivo una penna o
dato via un rene che sa fare vittoria
risvegliatasi nel mezzo del nulla che
poi perché non l'ha uccisa non si sa
chiama l'amica per farsi venire a
prendere se ben aiutami tu sai dove ti
trovi
sono le sette tracce si vienimi a
salvare ma dove non l'hai detto dove sei
ma lei che ha trovata comunque ok perché
era molto difficile aggiungere alla
sceneggiatura una frase tipo aiutami
sono in via fai presto troppo difficile
ma che è stato che vale ludico si tiene
lontana
sto parata ok basta citazioni di
fantozzini bidone sto accusando il
giorno dopo alberto esce di prigione e
lei gli racconta tutto così decide di
vendicarsi ma viene catturato portato in
un luogo isolato e credo drogato cosa
poi arriva l'amica di vittoria che lo
vede capisce che molto e va via
poi si inquadrano uno dei tre scalzacani
a cavallo che arriva ad un barbecue poi
si scopre che bruce willis era un
fantasma dall'inizio poi si scopre che
l'atterraggio numeri non è mai accaduto
scusate pensavo avessimo iniziato a
elencare cose a caso chiedo scusa ma non
dovevano rapinare il furgone portavalori
mi sono perso un pezzo di trama i tre
caballeros comprano una moto per
pedinare il furgone portavalori il
furgone portavalori il furgone
portavalori
perché quando i furgoni blindati
portavalori non ci sono possono essere
tranquillamente sostituiti da una punto
non vedo differenze ma ecco la chicca la
portata principale di questo piatto
orribile il gran visir di tutte le scene
orripilanti di tutti finché ho visto la
ciliegina sulla torta di sterco ecco a
voi il piano per rapinare il furgone
portavalori
il furgone portavalori si sposta tutti i
giorni è uno dei tre poliziotti deve
fermarsi per fare pipì
ogni giorno ogni giorno sempre nello
stesso punto del tragitto
[Risate]
questo non è un film
questi non sono attori è quella non è
una trama è solo l'ultima trasformazione
del demonio per apparire agli occhi dei
mortali non c'è altra spiegazione perché
non può esistere una persona che tenendo
in mano una penna sia riuscita a
scrivere una roba del genere senza che
nessuno al suo fianco le abbia detto
saber deve morire e come ulteriore
calcio nei [ __ ] si fanno fermare
dalla polizia per eccesso di velocità e
perdono di vista il furgone c'è su la
polizia scoprì il cadavere di alberto e
itg trasmettono la notizia è il tre
moschettieri si rendono conto di quanto
le blanc sia stronzo
l'investigatore riferisce al padre di
alberto la tragica notizia
se vi dico che non è vero mio dio
alberto non è possibile è possibile la
prima volta che sento una cosa del
genere alberto non è mai stato invece a
queste cose
dio onnipotente vittori e l'amica però
hanno un piano per vendicarsi di leblanc
come prima cosa chiamano il padre di
alberto l'amica si finge prostituta e si
fa caricare dal pe la pozzo
si no non state a chiedervi come facesse
a sapere dove fosse che avrebbe caricato
proprio lei la non lasciate perdere lo
porta in un luogo isolato e vittoria con
un revolver gli spara in mezzo agli
occhi
crepa bastardo
[Musica]
cosa ha sparato un mini cicciolo è come
se non fosse successo assolutamente
nulla si mettono a parlare dei lavori
che hanno trovato io dalla prossima
settimana avrò lavorare da mio zio peppe
è però gli animali li darà da mangiare
le farò anche il formaggio si alberto è
morto due minuti fa è detto che possa
cominciare a lavorare quando folle
insomma devo solo decidere quello che è
morto per colpa vostra e hanno chiamato
ieri sera dove riferire fra un paio di
giorni dovrei anche richiamare teheran
non ve lo ricordate già più l'amica di
vittoria si fidanza con un tizio che
deve chiudere un affare proprio con le
blanc ma pensate che culo ma
l'appuntamento arriva al padre di
alberto in cerca di vendetta
non capisco il motivo di questa
accoglienza questo è mio figlio a cui
fatto fare una fine tremenda che sarà la
stessa che farò fare a te
crepa bastardo
noi sembra rimanere
questo è fuori da ogni concezione fisica
esistente e e proprio è talmente brutta
questa scena che riesco a vederne la
vera essenza riesco a percepirne la
sostanza il calore proprio la vera forma
la vera chiave di lettura il suo chiaro
scopo orrore che la povera formale ai
celato il mio corpo ruolo tu hai
castrato con il tuo parlare strano
inorridisco perché ti stia scontando
ancora non capisco la scrittura berradi
mi lascia di stucco vero non può essere
e un barbatrucco dopo tante visioni che
li porto nel cuore
questa parte ho ancora terrore o
sardegna terra mia cara finisci questo
insulto ti prego spara
la cosa che non va
detto all'inizio e che a quanto pare il
film è stato finanziato direttamente
dalla sardegna stessa sipario